we live in a short-term world we're so
focused on what's right in front of us
whether that's our social media feeds
the latest political headlines or the
latest fashion trends like it's all
about now
and the problem is is that that kind of
tunnel vision of short-termism is
leading to a situation where we might
only be left with a short-term as a
species
so it's often said that we are the first
generation to truly feel the impacts of
climate change and the last generation
to meaningfully be able to do anything
about it
if short-termism got us into this mess
can long-termism get us out of it
[Music]
for us anything that we're saying we do
it in line that our seven generations
are sitting with us already
when you talk about
how can we establish things for the next
seven generations we're not just talking
about
the things that we can teach them but
the things that they have to know
to survive
[Music]
all my artwork deals with time on very
different levels some are quite
experiential like a mirror ball that has
ten thousand eclipses beaming around the
room and i've made clocks that tell the
time and other planets humans are kind
of evolved to think within our own
lifespans and so i think things like art
can allow you to take a step outside of
that but not in a kind of science
fiction way more in a way that connects
to earth and connects to living
organisms
[Music]
future library came about in 2014 we
planted a thousand trees just on the
outskirts of oslo and in a century's
time they're going to be cut down pulp
and made into book over the next century
100 authors are invited year by year to
write a new piece
every year the author brings their text
to the forest and people gather together
we go on the same walk through the
forest and then they present their
manuscript
[Music]
the questions have gone from thinking
about the paper book and digital you
know ways of reading and will the book
still exist too will humanity exist will
there be a reader in 100 years and
that's really shocking
my job description is set out in law is
to
act as the guardian of the interests of
future generations so i
feel pretty pressured by that that's
quite a big job description
the well-being of future generations act
was passed by our national assembly in
2015 it requires all of our public
bodies to demonstrate how they're taking
decisions in a way which meet today's
needs without compromising the ability
of future generations to meet their own
needs i suppose one of the biggest test
cases for the act was around building a
13 mile stretch of motorway it had been
previously thought that this was a done
deal not only is it potentially not the
right thing to do for future generations
we would also be asking them to pay for
it i asked the government to explain to
me how they were thinking about the long
term there and how they considered
future trends and scenarios and the
first minister came back and rejected
the proposals you know sometimes the
points are made as well we've got enough
problems to deal with now without
thinking about the future but i don't
think doing the right thing for current
generations and future generations
is mutually exclusive politicians are
not renowned for their long-term
thinking so actually taking a step not
just to say in some aspirational policy
document but actually in law no we will
require ourselves to think to the long
term and we'll appoint someone who is
independent and will hold us to account
for doing that that's quite a brave move
so we found that engaging with the long
term
changes the way that people behave in
the short term
stretching people's capacity to care
about future generations
means that they take responsibility
for that future
none of us is going to live forever
we're all mortal the question we're
asking is what do we want to leave
behind how can we leave a better legacy
for future generations how might we be
better ancestors
[Music]
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video